aquí tenemos la expresión 17 4 novenos
menos 12 dos tercios y te encargo que
pases el vídeo e intentes averiguar el
resultado correcto así que ahora vamos a
trabajarlo y lo que voy a hacer es
reescribir estos números mixtos y los
escribiré de la siguiente forma voy a
escribir este 17 17 enteros 4 novenos 4
novenos menos dos enteros dos tercios
pero esta vez voy a poner el 12 abajo
del 17 el 12 abajo del 17 y los dos
tercios abajo de los 4 novenos dos
tercios y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
dejar aquí muy claro que vamos a restar
los vamos a restar estos dos enteros dos
tercios de estos 17 enteros cuatro
novenos
lo primero que vamos a hacer es fijarnos
en la parte de la fracción y vamos a
empezar por restar la y bueno al hacerlo
vamos a ver que tienen denominadores
distintos
aquí tenemos novenos y aquí tenemos
tercios así lo que tenemos que hacer es
buscar un denominador común y el mejor
denominador va a ser el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 9 y 3 y quién va a ser
ese bueno pues vamos a pensar un poco en
eso vamos a empezar con el número más
grande entre estos dos en este caso es
el 9 lo voy a poner aquí el 9 y nos
vamos a preguntar
será el 9 divisible entre 3 y bueno pues
si el 9 si es divisible entre 3 por lo
tanto es divisible por el otro
denominador así que éste de hecho es el
mínimo común múltiplo si no lo fuera
entonces buscaríamos más y más múltiplos
de 9 por ejemplo iríamos al 18 al 27
etcétera y seguiremos buscando hasta
encontrar 1
fuera divisible entre el otro
denominador pero bueno en este caso no
tenemos que hacerlo porque 9 es
divisible entre 3 así que ya está am por
lo tanto puedo reescribir ambas partes
fraccionarias en términos de novenos la
primera bueno ya lo tenemos déjame
reescribirlo por aquí tengo 17 enteros
17 enteros 4 novenos 4 novenos y este
trabajo la puedo escribir como 12 déjame
ponerlo 12 enteros y bueno algo sobre 9
ok la pregunta es dos tercios cuántos
novenos van a hacer así que si el
denominador lo tuve que multiplicar por
tres para llegar a novenos entonces
tengo que multiplicar también el
numerador por tres para llegar a la
fracción que estoy buscando dos por tres
es 6 entonces lo voy a poner aquí dos
tercios
es lo mismo que seis novenos y ahora
como los dos tienen el mismo denominador
puedo intentar la resta de estos dos
números mixtos ya me puedo tomar la
resta de estos dos
pero ojo ten cuidado inclusive aquí al
intentar restar observa que aquí tengo
una fracción más grande que esta
fracción que tengo acá arriba tengo 4
novenos menos 6 novenos así que qué
puedo hacer aquí bueno la respuesta es
puede reagrupar podemos tomar un entero
de estos 17 enteros es más de una vez
vamos a hacerlo me voy a tomar un entero
de estos 17 enteros y por lo tanto me
voy a quedar con 16 enteros 16 enteros y
bueno ese entero que me estoy tomando
del lugar de los enteros se lo puedo
sumar a esta fracción que tengo aquí
porque un entero es lo mismo que 9
novenos entonces le voy a sumar 9
novenos
lo único que estoy haciendo es
reagrupando por aquí es decir tomo 9
novenos de estos 17 y esto porque 9
novenos es lo mismo que uno entonces
tomó nueve novenos del 17 y me quedo con
16 y estos nueve novenos los voy a
reagrupar para poderlo sumar a la parte
de la fracción al lugar de la fracción
piensa de un poco y bueno cuantos cuatro
novenos más nueve novenos bueno pues
esto de aquí va a ser exactamente lo
mismo que trece novenos que trece
novenos
y tal vez esta sea una forma interesante
de ver estos 17 enteros 4 novenos porque
esto es lo mismo que 16 enteros 13
novenos porque observa ahora este es más
grande que uno esto es lo mismo que un
entero cuatro novenos más 16 enteros
eso me da 17 enteros 4 novenos y porque
hice todo esto bueno porque ahora 13
novenos es más grande que 6 novenos así
que en este momento no puedo restar y
cuánto va a ser 13 novenos menos 6
novenos
bueno pues 13 de algo menos 6 de algo en
este caso estoy hablando de novenos eso
me dan 7 de ese mismo algo tres novenos
menos seis novenos es lo mismo que 77
novenos novenos y ahora puedo fijarme en
el lugar de los enteros y ver que 16
-12 los puedo restar y eso me da cuatro
enteros y con esto lo hemos logrado
la diferencia de 17 enteros 4 novenos
menos dos enteros dos tercios es igual a
cuatro enteros
siete novenos y ya está